olivia tell us your thoughts
yeah so it is all this money being
stored in the property market oh sorry
same things
my audio
can you hear me yes let's try and
continue for a second more
okay um yeah it's all this money being
stored in the property market uh it's
pretty galling sort of to hear if if
you're if you're a renter who can't get
on the property ladder and there are all
these people who are very very rich
indeed and avoiding the stamp duty which
is crippling so many people out of
buying their first home uh it's a
classic list of people um just exactly
as you would expect and
it you know it's the same as we've seen
five years ten years ago these stories
happen all the time uh very little seems
to change that at the moment it seems
like they're their evasion scheme so so
as though he says it's not it's not
clear that it's dirty money um but you
know it's morally questionable i think
perhaps we could say
yes and these types of stories um
as you say are pretty galling for
ordinary people who um can't evade tax
can't hide money um and uh literally
held to a different standard
yeah absolutely i mean it really feels
wonderful for them another rule for
everyone else i think particularly um at
the moment you know when we
we hear so much about young people
really struggling to get on the property
ladder um especially in london and the
south east when
it's up to the people are talking about
you know 60
of their take-home pay going on rent
and just absolutely no no chance at all
of owning a home and then if all of this
money is being stored up in property uh
a lot of these people will have second
homes third homes fourth homes in
exactly the places where
where young people are you know living
four to a two bed flat in in london so i
think yeah galling is is really the word
for it and as i say it's not the first
time this has happened
let's move on to the metro um while we
still try to establish a link with with
with zoe uh this is a story that's
broken tonight this is a metropolitan
police officer that's been held
on rape we've had comment from
christopher dick saying it's it's deeply
concerning um others would say that's an
under understatement really um
what are your thoughts olivia
yeah i think we're all getting a little
bit sick of cressida dick massively
underplaying the situation um i think
well personally i've been bit sickened
by the language that we've heard coming
after that over the past couple of weeks
about wayne cousins when they kept
calling him an ex-police officer
while he was a police officer at the
time that he committed this hideous
crime so in what respects an ex-police
officer that's a bizarre thing to say
and i'm sort of sure they'll be doing
the same with this and i don't really
like the way the mets dealing with these
horrible stories of their officers being
criminals um as well the details
obviously aren't clear on this i should
say now but but you know there is
clearly a strand of
hideous misogyny within the met police
force but the hierarchy seems to be sort
of treating it all as a as a kind of pr
exercise and trying to sort of paper
over the cracks and and and say uh
you know that i had someone calling us a
kerfuffle i mean
i don't think that crest or dick or the
rest of the hierarchy at the met have
quite grasped
what this means for ordinary women when
you've got officers being arrested for
for crimes like this
zoe i think you're back with us um would
you agree with that that perhaps
describing this is as deeply
concerning
isn't really enough well listen
i mean
there are a number of things going on
right there is an institutional problem
with the met that women
within the police force feel unable to
come out and and report fellow officers
behaving in a misogynistic inappropriate
abusive way because then they themselves
will find their position compromised so
there's obviously rock within the
general force and the notion that this
is just a couple a handful of bad apples
is species there's also a systematic
problem with the way
um
police officers are vetted right so
there is
a times revealed today this loophole
well it's not even a loophole the bar
for the crime you have to be convicted
of before you're barred from the police
is very very high you know you can
you can be proven to have indecently
exposed yourself and still be allowed
into the police that to me is the most
ridiculous situation because you really
have to
standards have to be very high you know
you wouldn't the doctor
who was sometimes drunk on the job you
shouldn't have a police officer who is
sometimes violently misogynistic
so thirdly there is obviously like a
just a programmatic problem in the
police that they've had all the
information on wayne cousins they've
known what was going to come out
at least since may or june if not before
then and their best response when that
did come out was further kind of met to
release release these absurd statements
which amounted to
we'll have more bobbies on the beat but
if you see us run away and flag down a
bus
and from alet of course who's in the
yorkshire post
um this victim blaming but also
really kind of undermining statement
that women should know better than to be
arrested by a loan officer that simply
isn't true you know i'm 48 years old i
didn't know that you shouldn't be
arrested by a loan officer i don't know
the protocol on that so the idea that if
you're street wise
you
raped and murdered
is it
really belongs i don't even want to say
in a different age it does not belong in
any police force and the idea that the
met could sit on this information which
they knew was coming out and have no
better institutional response than be
careful their lady we don't know what
our officers are up to
is
really problematic and i can't see this
dying down
olivia let's move on to the uh yorkshire
post or also looking um at this story
and as uh zoey mentioned there those
remarks from the um police are saying
that that uh sarah everard should have
known
not to to
to be arrested by a loan officer i mean
it does beg a belief doesn't it
it absolutely vegas believe but all the
reasons that zoe says i think the other
element that we haven't yet talked about
is is i mean
so shocking in so many ways but but the
other element is that
this was a lockdown arrest and one of
the problems is that the government
never completely made clear what the
laws were for lockdown you had matt
hancock coming on the tv every day
heavily implying that particular
activities were were forbidden by the
law when actually they weren't they were
just
not recommended by the government and
they deliberately made it very very
unclear what was a law and what wasn't
and then they expect a woman walking on
the street to know that what she's doing
isn't illegal when it was just so
unclear and i think the the fact that
the government handed these super super
super powers to the police during
lockdown when they hadn't properly been
been analyzed or or robustly uh
scrutinized at all
it's pretty shocking and that is part of
the problem so i think i mean this alex
got absolutely no
excuse justification at all and what he
said is is is his but i think i think we
should also be talking about the fact
that these powers were handed to police
the police didn't particularly
understand of course the public didn't
understand women didn't understand no
one really understood them and that is
an issue and i don't think it should be
allowed to happen again so of course mr
allen must just say um that he said he
won't be resigning and he's asked the
public to accept his apology um he's
admitted his remarks were misconceived
and insensitive
um i mean
this is this is really
it's not complicated stuff right i mean
he probably does deeply regret making
those remarks they they didn't reserve
any for him and they've brought this
reign of criticism down upon his head
but truthfully
he he showed scorn and contempt for
women on the back of a story in which a
young woman was murdered
so the fact that he's now a bit sorry
i don't think is
is really critical or germane
okay zoe and olivia for the moment uh
thank you we are going to take a break
coming up local authorities call for
council tax rise to help pay for the
social care black hole more about that
story in the tides after the break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now olivia lee and
hopefully we'll be joined by
zoe williams but you're appearing solo
for the moment olivia let's have a look
at the times um and this story
about well raising the question as to
whether council tax will be the solution
raising council tax will be the solution
for for plugging the social care black
hole
yeah i mean you can't blame councils for
wanting
uh the bigger council tax risers or big
accounts taxes and to spend because
obviously there is this enormous social
care black hole and the prime minister's
plan to fix it that we heard last month
turned out not really to be a plan to
fix it at all it was a plan to throw yet
more money at an unreformed nhs just
very thinly disguised as a plan to to
fix the council tax problem so of course
local councils um want to raise taxes
understandably um and the prime minister
obviously is looking like he might agree
to that the problem is that i think
we're going to talk about this in a
minute but but you then got on the front
of the express uh the prime minister
plans to cut taxes in in in the next
budget um obviously because his
conservative back benches feel very
uncomfortable at the economic direction
that this government seems to be moving
in um i know we've had we've had plenty
of back bench minute back benches some
tory back benches writing in the in the
daily telegraph we've had plenty of
grassroots stories writing into the
daily telegraph about how they don't
like the fact that the conservative
party seems to have become a party of
big tax it's become pretty much
indistinguishable from labor
economically um under boris johnson so
you've got boris asking
saying these two very different things
to two different groups of people to to
to local councils desperate for more
money he's saying yes perhaps we will
consider
a rise to to
to council tax to plug the social care
gap and then you've got him sort of
trying to pacify his back ventures at
conference with don't worry we're going
to lower taxes and i think we've seen
we're seeing this quite a lot with
forest johnson it's turning into a bit
of a pattern um our editor calls it
cake-ism it's all about having his cake
and eating it whoever he's talking to um
he wants to give them what what they
want uh and it's all part of this he
wants to be loved essentially um and and
that has its good points and it's bad
points um it makes them very electable
obviously um but i think we're going to
get to the point where people start to
say well wait a minute
what's he actually stand for what's his
vision what all of these promises really
mean yes and could be accused of mixed
mixed messages definitely and zoe local
authorities have warned that they need
an extra 2.6 billion a year and that's
just to sustain current levels that's an
awful lot of money that uh will need to
be found to to boost the social care
sector
well this is i mean it it's a really
interesting conundrum this because
people have been talking about rebanding
the council tax bands for
years and years and years it's long been
accepted that it's necessary because
they haven't actually been revised since
1992 right so
you're getting a situation now where the
top band is covering all properties from
what what counts as basically a starter
home in somewhere like the sydnem like
600 grand right up to two and a half
million pounds um and so you've got a
very very large number of people on very
different incomes and with very
different wealth all paying the same tax
so if you get local councils saying we
need more council tax
that will inevitably lead to a
rebounding which has
long been accepted was necessary by all
by people across the political spectrum
the reason why nobody ever did it was
because it is extremely combustible
right you're kind of basically saying to
people who thought they were
comfortable you're basically saying to
boomers
you now your
wealth
the wealthy you have that's greater than
the rest of the population now has to be
taxed and very it's
going to raise absolute hell so we must
leave it there uh we'll be back with you
out at 11 30 but for the moment olivia
and zoe thank you